hey guys how's it going so this is a
pretty exciting video because this is
something super cool that I just thought
was really cool and didn't realize that
everybody on the freakin Internet was
losing their mind today well today at 6
a.m. I was cruising through the airport
my sister and I stopped to Brookstone
looking at the luggage and blah blah
we're like wow look at this
it's get it this is cool 6 am really
freaking early and then I get to the
gate and I look on Twitter and all of
the trending topics is about this little
guy so yeah I got the email from Spiro
because I've been a fan of theirs for a
really long time we cover them like a
long time ago when they first came out
with this technology so this is pretty
exciting so let's open it up see what it
can do I am most excited to see about
what my dog thinks about it I don't
Phoebe let's open you like yeah it's
force Friday why not buy myself a toy I
was so excited I picked this up I forgot
to you know the t-shirts that I wanted
to get today hope you guys are all
celebrating with all the wonderful Star
Wars sales open up beanie oh my God he's
so cute I mean he was pretty much the
highlight of the trailer for me not
gonna lie
when everyone says that they literally
can't even hears your definition can't
even handle it
Maddie's gonna destroy this thing that's
for damn sure but how this stays on
there we're gonna find out though how do
you stay on please will break it already
seriously he's gonna chew this off in
two seconds
I wonder if that's important because if
it's not I'm gonna cut them off so the
pup doesn't need it so here we go okay
here's the base consuming it's wireless
charging looking at my directions seems
simple enough great packaging by the way
you guys did a great job here's our USB
cable it is just a micro USB this thing
was like 140 bucks pricey not sure what
that is in comparison to their other
Sphero balls we're going to stick this
where am I gonna stick it we'll just
slip it into my laptop I can't have to
put you down a little lower so you can
see the action ever plugged in it says
um - it says actually nothing there's no
words so okay so I guess that's kind of
just balancing it so that we can find
the bottom Oh things are happening and
then step
it does nothing again I'll let you go ah
I just looked holy crap
no you're freaking me out
oh please don't look at me if you turn
around and look at me I'm gonna lose my
mind
I'm looking at me he's looking at me
okay I got to go to Star Wars Sphero
calm you're freaking me out you wear a
mask oh go to bed you're freaking me out
breaking me out okay here it is get get
the app we're downloading it there it is
alright
we're were freakin rollin now things are
happening hold your device in your bb-8
baby it says it's connecting
initializing B become alive
firmware updating okay is it actually
updating is it just is it just making me
feel like it's doing something enjoy
your new bb-8 trust me I'm gonna enjoy
it just got a dog now I got a droid
there's nothing left in life take
control of my TV okay place TV on ground
in front of you I'm ready to place him
on the ground yet don't crouch shouldn't
close up Matty so that he won't come out
and try to break it right gosh socks in
these yoga pants looking so good
alright place him on the floor in front
of me okay the blinking blue right is
moving him BB is Amy's life use the AV
control
they move the bling blue right until
it's pointing towards you okay knew the
joystick to try and drive baby my
goodness he's he's drunk
go this way
oh my gosh he's too cool in here oh my
gosh
there's way too many things that I can
do with the big Delta how to do yet you
bug movie is freaking he's locked mine
he's lost mine Hey
oh he's like I even watch CBB I don't
want to see baby is it
what do you think of Bibi
what is it Maddy
what is it is that the joy he was
looking for
do you not real into it what do we say
huh okay here here big boy
he's not that much bigger than the Droid
Oh baby don't worry I'm here for you the
brave little pup be brave
do you care
okay let's let baby along alright guys
thanks so much for watching those a
quick little overview of the new bb-8
droid by Spiro it's pretty cool it can
do a bunch of other things too but I
need to do a little more research before
we get into that so yeah stay tuned for
some more videos blackmailing little
baby puppy Maddy is gonna be super into
it let me know if any of you guys
actually manage to get one of these a
little link in the description to an
amazon link where I found a couple of
these guys if you guys are interested in
checking that out I'm gonna go take the
puppy to go potty now see you later
did you have money haircut can you even
tell if it's any different